hi my name is aquafina and i am in the
movie
oh my god
we're just gonna go harass some of the
other cast members because that's what
i'm great at doing i'm a professional
schnoozer first on the list mr simulu
[Music]
i have the most fun when i'm on set with
you because we have such a natural
chemistry we do okay right now
we feel like when we bicker it's really
like two best friends victory oh yeah
for sure
if you could get out are you serious
come on man
what's up razor fist
it's a cool gadget i would say it is a
cool gadget you'd be a great
thanksgiving carver yeah just chop chop
chop chop what's it like to be on a
movie with me cool yeah it's cool right
i would advise that self-control i'm
eating a full onion
you're going in that building
yeah thank you yeah of course you're
welcome
tony you play when woo
you having fun
no
yes yes yes yeah yeah
this is my first time working with an
very nice yeah they are thank you tony
that was lovely yeah we brought him back
in one piece hi i'm driving directly in
the middle hello hi hidden say hi
oh my god
you have a license i have a license to
kill
but no not an official license now